Hong Kong harbour is usually one of the
busiest in the world with hundreds of
ferries cruise and container ships
passing through every day but as the
corona virus outbreak is worsened the
economy has slowed and the waters have
become quiet the situation is a lot
worse in mainland China where according
to one estimate lockdowns and business
closures may have already cost almost
200 billion dollars this year but as the
economic price of this outbreak goes up
the damage to the environment is going
down
studies show that a drop in coal and oil
use in China have reduced carbon dioxide
emissions by at least 25 percent and
levels of general air pollutants are
also significantly down across key
industrial indicators such as coal-fired
power stations and steel production and
there have been big reductions 15 to 40
percent in each of those indicators and
in aggregate we think something like 100
million tons of co2 hasn't been emitted
compared to last year there are less
emissions elsewhere too much of the
global supply chain has been broken by
the disruptions in China factories and
countries like Cambodia and Vietnam
can't get enough raw materials from
China so our slowing down or suspending
operations and the International Air
Transport Association expects global
demand for air travel to fall by almost
five percent this year in Asia that
number could be higher less demand means
fewer planes in the air and a decrease
in emissions we've seen this sort of
thing before like during the 2008 global
financial crisis but after that economic
slowdown China looked to make up for
lost time by introducing a massive
stimulus plan designed to get the
economy moving again meaning any
environmental gains were soon lost
China's government has already promised
tax cuts and other assistance to help
companies bounce back from the economic
impact of the outbreak President Xi
Jinping wants a quick recovery but that
could be risky I think the leaders in
Beijing are very eager to restart the
economy we have already seen some of the
factories sequentially opened but the
concern is that you know if the workers
started to come back to the companies
and offices there could be a potential
second wave of the spread of the virus
workers will also be wanting to start
earning again after many company
suspended wages because of the downturn
as China's economic engine starts
turning over again scientists will be
watching with interest what happens to
the environment as a result Wayne hey al
Jazeera Hong Kong